Hey,
what's going on?
How are you doing?
Just checking in on you on Thursday payday.
I am actually in a,
I don't even know where I'm at.
I'm somewhere in upstate New York and I am bring shut up.
I need an intro.
Your first,
sorry.
How dare you,
how dare you talk before he intro.
I am bringing back a,
a,
uh,
a popular guest.
We like to say here at the Monday morning podcast facilities,
which is basically wherever the hell I'm at.
I know where I'm at.
I'm somewhere in item and I'm going to say where I don't want people to know,
but people do know that this man is the King of New Jersey,
Ladies and gentlemen,
the pride of Trenton.
Paul Versey.
Yes.
Back on the podcast.
And I am a up here and,
uh,
somewhere upstate New York because we're going to be doing a,
a benefit tonight.
Yeah.
Elevli live little.
These Allen there.
Levelly live.
We are northern Westchester.
We could leave it and then we can leave it at that northern Westchester County.
It's creepy as Illuminati neighborhood up here.
I was,
we,
we did,
we did the Tarrytown music hall last night
and,
uh,
afterwards I was driving up,
you know,
verse he gives me directions to his,
for his place and it was just fog.
No street lights in every three feet.
There was a sign about a deer.
That's how I like it except the deer because you know,
I hit a deer.
No,
I love it.
I love it up here.
But it would be nice if they got street,
all this,
all this blood money up here from all these pieces of Shit bankers that worked
down on Wall Street and,
and,
and these boys,
the Smith Barney's of the world,
they can't get street lights.
You know why the vampires corporate sand pipes of corporate franchise,
natural bill,
they're trying to keep going with,
they're trying to do yes.
Natural in the woods.
You know,
Deon supposed to be here on street lights when you're talking about maybe do you
lit it up,
they just stare at that instead of running out in front of your car.
Dude,
it was so scary.
Driving home last night.
One of those things,
like the fog was so thick,
you're not supposed to put on your bright lights,
which you probably,
you probably don't know that in fog.
You don't put on your bright lights.
Now you can't hear it makes it worse.
Yeah,
I know that.
Yeah.
Do to George Stephanopoulos.
I got to talk about that.
I've got a dog that we got.
We got back up.
We got to tell her that we had one of the sickest weeks ever.
So,
um,
I'm doing the benefit,
the garden of dreams,
the garden of dreams.
It makes a gardener laughs.
It makes a,
you know,
underprivileged kids,
whatever.
They have a dream.
They make it come true.
It's a great charity.
I'm doing it.
See,
I'm doing it sad.
So the people at Msg,
they own a bunch of theaters around the country,
uh,
and they booked me in them.
And uh,
we both make money together.
So they call me,
say,
you want to do this benefit?
And I said,
hey,
why wouldn't I,
why wouldn't I have to?
All you guys have done for me,
so be in the weasel that I am.
I immediately,
you know,
I'm checking out there,
the rain,
the rangers schedule and I'm,
I'm seeing that play in the king's on Tuesday night.
So I call one of the [inaudible] brothers,
the tough like fucking shoe,
those muscles.
Okay,
great.
So I call up,
uh,
I'm texting with Steve and I just say,
hey man,
it,
is there any way if I come in early,
you know,
the Rangers got a game.
Is there anywhere,
if when they're done with that practice,
if I could throw on a pair of skates and just do a couple of laps around the
Madison Square Garden.
Nice.
And he goes,
dude,
let me get on that.
Let me see what's up.
Next thing you know,
cause he's a [inaudible] from a lineage of Chris,
Steve,
look the Hanson brothers,
except they're not,
they're not stupid.
They get shit done.
Right.
And what's his other brother's name?
So Matt,
yeah,
Matt.
Great Guy.
So,
uh,
he calls me back.
Next thing you know,
we got a pick up game and we're playing in a x rangers.
Yeah.
X rain ranges out there.
Um,
hang on one second.
I got to justice level here.
Um,
and yeah,
next thing you know,
we're out there,
we're playing on the ice laid law.
Oh my God,
that guy was hilarious.
The guy was hilarious.
And Brian Mullen,
Brian Mullen.
Yeah.
Part of the uh,
the,
the royalty of the Mollen Fam Joy Mullen.
Uh,
and Brian,
I believe two of them made,
I think three of them.
One of them made it I think up for a minute.
That's just insane dude.
When you come from a family where like two or three people,
that's why no one will ever beat the solder brothers is Sutter.
Buttes had seven brothers all made it to the NHL and at one point I think they
will all playing.
Yeah.
And at the,
I think there was like 24 teams in the league and you've got seven brands.
Like the Molina brothers had three catchers catching the bigs for that,
which is pretty incredible to have three catchers.
But uh,
so we're all dressed like we're doing crash test dummy shit and these guys don't
even have helmets on and that,
which is really dangerous.
Like,
cause he know I said to him,
I said,
I said at the time I was like,
dude,
you're going to go out there with us hacks with that sticks dude.
You gotta be careful.
He was fine dude.
That guy,
his ability to position his body because he kept fucking with me for some reason
right out of the gate that I loved you too.
That's had it.
He had it out for you guys that fake fight or you throw the gloves down.
Then he went down in the ground and he was joking.
I tripped him.
I got him one time.
I just go here.
Here's birth slap shot.
He's just joking like I loved you dude.
I know you get a perfect impression of my awful one time.
I was doing my one timer.
Uh,
but you know what I ended up scoring.
Yeah he did.
I did on a goalie too.
So accounts in my world.
You know what's funny?
I was trying to go five hole and it actually client off the but the left post I
just played it off like they even know file.
That's how much a non hockey between the legs,
between the legs.
I just tried to put it on net and I figured at some point,
yeah,
if I have 200 shots,
I mean one of them's got to go and you take the biggest hack in the world.
It takes two and a half court shots.
At one point it's going to go off the back board and through the ramp.
I can't believe me.
And you ran into each other before anything started?
Just I know and I went down.
You stayed up?
I almost went down.
No.
Did you go down?
I wobbled dude.
Our cages like the cage hit and my head was on wall.
That was my fault.
I wasn't looking.
I felt bad about that.
You know,
if I do what you got to get to when we went to the game,
we've got to get to the George Stephanopoulos.
All right,
so for you guys that don't know,
I'm bad with directions,
is that fair to say?
Yeah,
I would say it's fair to say when you get lost in Manhattan,
in the fucking streets and the number,
but I'm not good with directions.
Never was.
But bill here,
your beloved host is horrible with names,
right?
Like messes names up of of players.
Be like,
dude,
I'm telling you right now.
I'd be like,
just going to help me remember for so long.
He's going to many Rivera.
I go,
dude,
who are you talking about it?
It was,
it was Mariano Rivera.
So we're at that were at the hockey game.
Amazing seats.
They hooked us up with like we're right there at the bench and uh,
you know,
there's all celebrities nearest and stuff,
it's like drunk and I'm yelling at title at all.
Sam,
you saw do,
it's hilarious.
Hanks was there.
Sarah Jessica Parker.
You just see everybody,
right?
So all of a sudden you see all the steps and all of a sudden feel just go,
I have my head down because the guy poured me a vodka that was like a leader and
they'll just sit in there.
All of a sudden I hear it bro.
Bill just goes due to George Stephanopoulos to George stuff and I was right
here.
[inaudible] I look up and in one second I recognized that it was Jeff fucking
Gordon,
the race car with his wife and everybody.
The second is to go to any book,
Jeff Gordon and I just looked at bill.
I go,
George Stephanopoulos,
you're going do,
you can't tell me there's a resemble do they look alike?
I'm telling you right now,
someone's going to do it.
Somebody do this,
please send the splitscreen.
Yeah.
Oh,
they look or they could be brothers.
Uh,
Georgia's the older one,
right?
Do,
do you have a younger one who had no pressure?
What is,
he was always the younger one.
So he kept himself in better shape.
Maybe you got a better look at how good it is.
Jeff Gordon looked.
Oh my God,
thank God he was so dreamy.
That guy was just like,
what are you talking about?
What do you mean guys?
Like wasn't got 50 Jeff Gordon.
Is it,
you know,
it's funny.
I have no idea.
I know I'm way older than he is though.
Oh,
I mean,
I don't remember like I was winning titles when I was in high school.
He's just,
maybe I'm thinking your driver's license at 16 I mean those guys go out.
They start to stock car racing.
You know what?
16 and a half maybe.
I'm thinking this guy's older than he is a race.
Those ghost car Golkar things around the 23rd he looked like a 35 year old man
in shape.
The average agent stock cars like 18 oh,
okay.
All right,
so then you know what?
He's probably in his forties my bed,
dude,
he's probably like 29
no.
Yeah,
there's no Jeff Gordon.
There's no way Jeff Gordon out what it is,
what you want,
but to breathe in all that exhausted and wrinkles up you face when I'm telling
you it's 2029 it wasn't out of shape.
Doll crushing it,
dude.
The average age is not 17 what?
Stock car?
They don't start without.
I'm just fucking with you.
Do Dale Earnhardt Sr rest his soul that did was racing cars when he was before
he went.
I know they're doing that,
but I'm saying you don't make it to the,
to,
to the shell,
Paul.
Oh,
to the big,
you know,
we don't make it to the Daytona 500.
I haven't seen it actually happen.
No idea what I'm talking about.
That I'm never going to be able to watch good morning America or see George
Stephanopoulos his face without bursting out laughing.
I don't understand how he went from a serious on the other side of the,
of the podium being like,
uh,
the uh,
accidentally sent off a missile today that landed in a fucking school yard.
Right.
And now he like interviews Justin beaver.
Yeah.
Like that's a hell of a transition.
Now what he thinks,
what's winning things more impressive,
what he did or what?
Um,
um,
the guy with the big gap between his teeth and not Richard see stray.
Stray a strand.
Yeah.
By far I think it was,
yeah,
because I think straight hand came from a world of,
you know,
world string.
It came from with this world of athletes.
And here's,
here's the other thing,
straight.
How many hall of fame athletes can get that main stream?
I mean,
Michael Strahan does a good morning America dancing with this status live with
Regis.
I mean live with Michael and Kelly and Michael or whatever.
He took over that,
that thing.
And he's really good at it.
You know,
he's really,
really good at it.
Um,
I don't know.
I'm being biased to him because he was in the crowd.
Oh,
you're right.
He's 43 Jeff Gordon is 43.
I thought he was older than that.
Well,
you know,
I got to,
I got them by three years,
right?
Three years.
Yeah.
He's gonna be,
he's gonna be 44 in August 4th always a Leo.
Paul was crushing it.
Dot.
Like you could tell that dude,
he just came in with a jacket.
There's something about a race car driver.
They do have to keep themselves in great shape.
They have to stay like light.
You can't add weight to the fucking car.
He can't come in like a tub of shit.
Tony Stewart.
It's kind of like the,
he's kind of like the heavy guy,
but there's not many.
There's always that John Daly Guy in every sport there is.
There is except hockey really and have Negro.
If you find that as it as a hoop fan.
Yeah.
Now that you've played hockey,
what's so hilarious about Paul Versey is he has skated like five times in his
life and the fifth time he skated at Madison Square Garden.
Now Hey,
you're a New York fan.
What was that like?
Skating around looking up,
trying to find those New York and the championship.
Man,
that must've been half year ice time.
It was insane.
No seriously.
It wasn't saying there was one point where like when all you guys got off,
I went to the locker room,
I think me and Missoula,
his brother were out there alone and they dimmed the lights,
but the lights were still on the ice and I remember I was like,
I just need to take the sense.
So I just did a lap around the garden with the garden empty and I'm looking at
all the black seats and I just looked up and I saw the Ewing and all that and I
was just like,
this is,
I really tried to soak it in.
That's all it was.
It was really cool man.
Yeah.
What I did was I tried to get to the locker room first because I wanted to be
the first dude in the shower cause I only saw one shower and I was like,
I'm going to be sitting there forever.
Yeah.
And I,
that's the one thing that weirded me out though.
Like just old guys just throwing their fucking,
just peeling their underwears off when they're sweating.
Like,
like dude,
seriously though,
like don't you have it in you to just keep,
I don't know.
Maybe it's all,
I've got to tell you something.
There's this 10 years between you and me and there's a big 10 years like,
like when I grew up,
when you took gym class that we were like animals,
we all went into the same fucking shower.
That was like a,
there was like three sections of the shower with like,
you know,
five,
uh,
shower heads on each side.
I know.
And I remember the first time we were in sixth grade,
it was the first time we were all sitting at the little kids,
like we're all going to in the same thing.
And I remember like the first week of shout,
a of gym class,
most kids didn't shower because you were too nervous or shy or whatever.
And like five kids did it.
I remember mean this other kid,
his kid,
dad bashner what a great fucking name,
right would die in laughing.
Everybody who didn't shower would die laughing,
watching their friends walked by Butt ass naked.
And then within like three gym classes,
it was completely normal.
Everybody did it and you need,
didn't even notice.
So I just,
I grew up like that.
Yeah,
I didn't do that in my school at all.
But as steam room when somebody does weirds me out because there's something
about how it's,
it's this relaxing meditative thing and then all of a sudden there's somebody's
Dick and you're just like,
dude,
you're killing it for me.
Where did we go?
We went through a steam in Toronto and I walked away and like,
dude,
I guess the dude was just,
I just flipped.
Dude's just bunk balls out.
He's like,
yeah man,
how's it going?
Like they just have no,
they have,
we were joking about like,
oh,
you were saying what's wrong with guys like that?
And the,
I'm like,
those guys are the straightest guys that defect that it doesn't even dawn on
them who is telling the story where the guy was talking to him and the guy had a
hairdryer outmost blow drying his ball.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Uh,
one,
one of my unacceptables on diversity affects,
somebody goes,
I'm in the thing and the guy's just sitting there talking sports.
I think.
I didn't think I was just talking and it was just blow drying his dick and balls
just like,
like it was nothing to do with that.
And my thing about that is people like,
people think that's weird.
It's like that guy that is as heterosexual,
the fact that they wouldn't dawn on you,
you're just sitting there going like,
ah,
that's so the Barneys is blowing through his pew.
You know what?
Me and my friend,
me and my friend,
this is the one of the funniest things.
I was still the funniest thing to this day and we used to laugh in highschool
cry when an old man is at a urinal and he farts while he's pissing,
it's one of the funny own.
It's almost like it's,
they can't control it.
It's the second day just released to let to let them,
but there's something about it where they don't,
they're still older.
There's 60 or 70 they don't even smile and it's always,
it's,
it's always a baritone too.
Never,
never a high pitched one
did.
There's just something about an old man not giving a fuck.
That is the greatest
old men just don't care.
They don't care.
They announced what they're doing.
Yeah,
I got to go down there.
They're the funniest dude.
Old Men are funny.
Dude.
I know.
What did you,
what year in your life do you think you tap out from giving a fuck?
Like what year do you think you're just,
no,
I actually,
I was actually talking to my wife about retirement and she's like,
you had in mind you're going to die on stage.
You're going to do this forever.
I say,
I might,
but I wanna.
I wanna plan like,
you know,
like look,
this is this weird thing with age I'm at right now.
I started 23 years ago.
All right.
I was 23 almost 24 now I'm 23 years later,
46 almost 47 in 23 I'll be 70 right,
right.
Do I really want to be,
I don't want to have to be doing it.
I don't want to have to be lugging my ass all.
You wouldn't have to what?
What it's going to come down to is say a legend or the funny boats now,
but would you be doing it for 50 years?
Please welcome.
We were talking about this the other day,
like
bags.
Don Rickles is like in a wheelchair doing it now and it's like,
I think he loves it so much.
He still wants to talk and tell stories.
I think he loves it that much.
Right.
If you want to do it at 70 I mean Carlin rest his soul.
He passed away at 71 and he was still doing it and I think of George Chrono
lived to 85 he would have done it to 85 I really don't think you would have done
it.
Like I would have just kept going with it,
but my thing is I want to,
uh,
if,
if I want,
do you have to take a Piss,
Paul?
No,
I can't burn another pizza.
Oh,
the pizza.
Yeah.
I would say thank you.
You saved my house by the way.
Oh yeah.
Put my son.
My son used to go,
I want pizza and I had a pizza in form and bill just add an order goes,
you want pizza?
And I go,
Oh yes,
there was a hockey puck.
Right.
He's making some digiorno homemade versus house here.
It's not delivered.
I hate that it's not delivery.
It's like,
yeah,
no shit.
It's a frozen pizza.
That's such genius marketing.
Whenever they,
yeah,
and if you've noticed in the last 10 years,
everybody who makes shitty food is always at now trying to do this thing where
they have morons.
All right.
Who Wake up every day,
eight and frosted flakes.
They sit them down at a,
at a table and they,
the first thing they do to mind,
fuck them is they give them cloth napkins and then they sit down and they bring
them like olive garden or they bring them dominoes or they bring Digiorno and
these people are blue.
All my God,
it's so decadent.
What is this?
Believe it or not,
it's Dunkin donuts.
Are you theory?
I thought this was for my Boulos Yuri and Patty.
No,
it's a fucking doughnut from down the street.
Oh,
look at this.
Me TV.
Oh,
Paul,
you got to see this man.
Rockford files is on right now.
You're a Firebird guy.
I,
you know,
started whenever I used to watch this.
Look at that caddy chick pulling up red leather seats.
Red On red.
Look at her coming out noser place.
God Damn it.
I love to be living in the seventies I'm just kidding.
They were already bitching by then,
throwing their hats in the air twirling around in Minneapolis who can turn no
world on with her Claire,
who can take got another job suddenly make it all sema.
Well,
let you pitch in.
You should know it,
bitch it show it first is fuck it back.
He made up pizza.
You're welcome people.
Sorry man.
That was even bad for me.
Dude.
You're like,
you ever watched this Rockford files?
No,
he,
I never noticed this,
but he's not married.
He's got no kids and he lives in a trailer down by the beach.
He's really like a loser and his dad drives his truck like a,
I don't know what happened to him as a kid,
but he's got this sick ass.
Look at this gold file.
It's like a chain out.
He's got to right there.
That gold Firebird except body style you like.
You know it's funny,
as you were describing his life,
me being married with two kids,
I'm thinking to myself,
this guy's crushing it.
You're like,
yeah,
he's got a trailer by the beach,
not married,
nothing else.
Firebird.
Oh my God.
Could go smoke a Cuban by the beach every night by himself,
without having a woman Gal and only knowing your mouth.
And he brings the same lawn chair that he uses his like his dinner table chair
just brings it right on to the beach.
It's perfect.
Is that,
gee,
that's not Jennifer Garner's father or grandfather,
is it?
Uh,
that's James Gunn on and look at this fire,
but at that Firebird,
that's fine.
He looked at me front end on it.
You're a Pontiac guy.
Paul Versey was one of the last Americans to buy a Pontiac.
Like when I first met you.
What are Nice Suv,
but you know,
like SUV.
Now if you ask me the name that I could never,
but you want to know the star fire and there was a window of the son of what's
called a torrent.
But you know why I got it torn.
You know what?
It got me,
you know what got me when I thought not the white on the outside.
I like the front grill.
But you know what really got me when I opened it,
it was cr cream leather.
You know how I like light leather?
No,
I like that.
And I go dude,
light leather with white.
I'm in.
And then the guy just got me,
you,
me and Stacy had no intention of buying it and I sat in it and I just looked at
the letter and I'm like,
it's not a bed.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
Well that's my thing that's taught people.
I wasn't going to tell him I was going to get,
I'm going to get to 65 Ford Galaxy.
I'm gonna sit Dan Guy,
I showed you a picture of that car.
Right?
Oh that's beautiful car.
Yeah.
I want to get,
I want to have the white leather interior matching top and then some other sick
ass color.
And then underneath it's just all 2015 I'll be able to drive it across country.
Um,
that's,
that's the game plan.
I just have to find,
I got to find an old one.
People keep telling me well by one that somebody already started to fix up and
it sits like that.
Cause there's always shit that they did to it that I don't,
I'd rather start at ground zero.
Just find one that's straight body.
I think I want the black trans and what the gold bird on it.
Of course you do,
Paul.
I always said that about you dude.
You're right down main street.
Well what is your ham and Egger this,
this,
this.
There's no left turns with you.
It's not true.
It is.
I like Buicks and I'm probably,
the only thing missing in your house is a sign that says home sweet home.
I'm telling you,
if you don't think she's got that,
we got that.
Paul Versey got days America.
I think we got that.
Hey,
what about that Italian meal we had?
Oh,
just happy.
Yeah.
Giuseppe is a guy,
uh,
who is been,
he's from Sicily.
He's been in America 13 years and he owns a restaurant right over near,
um,
never been arrested right now.
You got to get that out there.
He made a homemade nilkie.
Oh my God.
Was it good?
Yeah.
You know,
like shit.
Oh,
this cat.
Yeah,
it's a big boy.
I get along with animals,
man.
People not so much animals like
you know what I like about animals?
They did.
They don't,
they don't feed me every once in a while.
Give me a little pat on the head.
You know Angela Lazada Comedian Angela was on it.
He was always a dog guy.
He didn't like cats,
so it was girl finally talked him into getting a cat.
All he does is post on Facebook,
pictures of his cat and I talked to,
I go,
dude,
they're under already.
He goes,
underrated be in.
Although he says be,
I love that.
He still says be underrated.
Beat y'all.
What's that?
And he goes,
what's up?
Pop underrated be.
Yeah,
he stuck with it.
No,
there's nothing better than a cool cat.
My only issue with them,
I snuggled,
you're my only issue with cats is I don't like when they're done with you
petting them,
why can't they just sort of shake you off?
They always get all of a sudden roll over in the back like Lightening Quick and
Dick Dick Clause in a little bit.
It's like,
all right dude.
He could tell a cool and don't want to bother him.
That's why he was like,
all right,
I could show what this guy,
he doesn't let you know.
The funny thing about cats is they fucking,
they,
when they say they like tolerate you living with them,
which is the funniest thing,
like you feed them and bring them in and then they tolerate you.
It's like,
excuse me.
It's something hilarious.
Oh yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Then dogs are totally codependent.
Needy do.
My dog is like,
it's like a psycho chick.
Like we go to leave it alone.
It's like freaking out.
Where were you?
Oh my God.
I had to tear up the entire living room,
not my dog.
It's like,
it's like when are you going to understand that you're not being abandoned?
We come back.
All right,
next thing you know,
you're up on the couch and I'm giving you a belly rub and you fall asleep.
What is the problem?
Yeah.
Now because you know,
because probably because you didn't get it from a puppy.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the deals was.
That dog.
All I know is I fucking love the dog,
so I'm stuck with it.
Things already like,
uh,
like seven years old already.
We got it.
And it's like a year,
year and a half when we got it.
So it's like she's,
she's only halfway there.
Do they go 14,
15 years now I'll do it the way I'm treating this dog,
this dog is,
and make it like 18,
and it's
changing the oil.
I'm baby this things that,
and this thing has very low miles on it.
I'd take it for a hike every day.
That's all I do is I,
I,
uh,
the things the best,
the only thing about that is she's going to need that every 10 now.
What do you mean?
Like you can never stop doing that hikes.
You're going to lose it if you do that.
Oh,
what's,
and then what's,
what's the downside that I stay in shape?
No.
Yeah,
that's true.
Um,
they still do commercials like this.
What's that?
Yeah,
it was just for old people.
Oh,
that's gotta be the worst dude.
When you,
everybody's moved out.
Whoever you're married,
died,
and now you're there.
Just thinking,
I hope I don't fall down.
It's going to be horrible.
That's like one of the biggest leads to them.
Dinah's I'm falling.
Oh yeah.
My 94 people is so unbelievably uncoordinated.
It's like,
haven't you been walking for like almost a century?
what is the problem?
All they need,
dude is a throw rug and that like that could be cause of death.
Speaking to uncoordinated,
how hammered did we get two nights ago?
I didn't want to talk about it.
I was embarrassed.
Easily.
You held it together fine.
Oh yeah.
He held it together.
I yelled at all,
Sam.
Uson too much,
dude.
I've been to sporting events with you or you were a thousand times more
embarrassing when you started yelling at him.
I thought when you started yelling at him in the first period,
dude,
you were,
I wasn't.
I would just,
I just kept going.
I kept going.
Oh Dude.
I was crying on me,
dude.
I was crawling.
Dog Acts like he didn't get no,
he knocked him out.
You live by the sword.
You die by the sword.
Just like the clip said.
No dude,
I was crawling in my skin when we went,
but I stopped.
I stopped though because I finally was just like,
you know what?
This guy could beat the living shit out of me and not even wrinkle is tying that
dolphins game.
You made me cringe.
You were the bangle fans told me to get on the,
on the dolphins kicker.
You were so relentless that I literally had my head down.
You're,
hey,
you're good.
You weren't that poor guy was pacing.
No,
I got him to walk down the other side.
You got,
I saw.
I thought you might do that.
And I'm like,
I don't think he's going to do that here sitting on garden because now you start
looking at him though.
You kept looking at him every once in a while.
And uh,
we,
we went to wasn't even though was a dirty player,
but then when it came time to fight anyone,
just turtle up.
It just,
I mean it's just how do you look your dad and the,
I did do something like that.
It's just the worst.
Ah,
um,
ah man.
Did it cut out?
Oh No,
this is,
I always think this happens to seize frigging headphones.
I feel like I ended up losing the recorder.
Do the battery life on this new,
uh,
I'm gonna give him a free plug here.
This Olympus Ls,
whatever.
It's up to 17.
I just leaned down.
I just had a total paranoid of the cat was going to scratch the shit out of my
face.
You never know what these things.
He would never in a million years,
he would know.
I know it him cats,
cats have the loyalty of like,
no,
he's great.
He's a sweetheart.
The other walker,
he's good.
That's hilarious.
The way my friend,
he gets hookers.
Oh,
I've got a friend of mine.
He likes street walkers.
You know?
Why would you see other day three walkers?
I was thinking that the other day.
How many different names that are for that?
Streetwalkers hilarious prostitute,
hooker,
streetwalker whore,
whore.
Who were harlot?
What was the one?
One.
One of Kevin's friends.
Don't make stomp it.
No,
something like that.
That's ridiculous.
That actually seems like that almost doesn't make it sound bad.
Yeah.
I have to look that up to him.
I'm probably saying it wrong.
Strumpet now dude.
Paul,
I can't believe we're playing again today.
I can't believe a,
okay,
hang on a second.
I gotta look that up.
I can't believe that I can play hockey again today.
Look at that structure at crossing the street.
I can't believe it.
Like an abandoned your your beautiful baby boy.
Oh look,
he's an angel up during this pepperoni pizza watching cartoons.
That's it.
Stop it.
Here we go.
Is it stomp it?
Yeah.
This is probably like some fancy definition.
It's a fancy trumpet made out of gold.
Stomp it.
A definition of strap prostitute.
Wow.
Stomp it on of origin.
Another term for who were first used by Shakespeare to describe loosed women.
Dude,
that's fucking ad.
Then we went down the block.
I picked up a couple of man.
Yes.
Jampie its
gift to Gab.
Drump it.
Well listen,
this is actually a few,
if you're new to this,
um,
podcast,
I'm starting to do these every Thursday where I just sort of bang out a half
hour and then we,
uh,
we play some greatest hits.
So,
because Paul Versey yeah,
Paul Versey is here.
Uh,
we actually have,
you're a classic clip from the time machine.
What would you,
what not,
don't,
don't ruin it,
but if you haven't,
if you missed that episode or you're new to the podcast,
I was traveling with Paul through the frozen Tundra of Canada a bunch just about
a year ago.
Hello?
Halau knock knock.
We,
we,
like you said,
uh,
we ran out the winter there,
right?
We wrote out the winters in Canada.
This is the almost a year.
Yeah.
And it brought what brought my hockey shit up there.
We skated on the canal there in Ottawa,
not knock.
Oh yeah.
Knock knock.
We,
this tour manager,
she would do that.
We would be sitting in the green room talking and she'd be like all the way down
the hall and just go knock,
knock.
Hello.
But it never knock.
Never.
That's the funniest thing.
Knock her.
Announcing those zero excuse to just interrupt the conversation.
That was a lot of fun.
That uh,
what would you do?
What do you mean the time machine time machine before 1900.
Oh yeah.
Say So.
Basically spinning off here.
Uh,
so basically as you know,
people always say,
if he had a time machine,
what would you do?
Would you go into the future?
Would you go to a period during your life wants you have to go before 1900 and
stay?
Oh,
you had,
the question was if you had to go in a time machine and you had to go before the
1900 and stay,
where would you go?
That was what the question is.
Christ.
Yeah.
I think I said I'd go to 1900.
No,
you said you would go to the 18 hundreds and don't
make the clip pointless.
I'm so fucking ridiculous.
I don't remember what I said.
So anyways,
we're doing this side,
this benefits and I do that.
How great was a Tarrytown last night?
Oh,
it was great.
Tarrytown musical.
It's one of the great theaters in this country.
So much fun.
And I was asking,
I was saying like,
man,
does anybody ever taped this special here?
And they were like a Jim brewer taped the specialist.
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
[inaudible] Trevor Noah,
Trevor Noah.
Just did one there.
Okay.
And Lamp Annelies doing one this weekend,
which I'm sure is already sold out.
Yeah.
Now it's just like the,
it's the,
I dunno.
It's got this,
it's cool.
It's got the magic in there,
Paul.
It does.
Some places have the magic.
That place definitely does.
Um,
had a great time there last night,
ended up.
Um,
so there's no point in driving all the way back to the city.
Actually,
there was a great point because it was a longer drive to where I have a place in
the city compared to where the fuck you live now.
You just didn't know how to get up here.
You didn't know how to get up here.
It was foggy.
And you,
and I tell you,
telling me that my gps doesn't know how to do it.
No,
you're looking at the GPS.
You're going slow.
It's foggy or worried about going slow.
Moodley no,
no,
no I did.
And I'll tell you why because I said in my head,
Versie already hit a deer.
So right there,
what are the odds that I'm also going to hit the deer cause I'm going to the
same place where he lives.
It's done for a while for,
you
know what I did was I got behind this maniac and one of those dodge ram trucks
that was driving crazy.
So I just drafted behind them.
I'm like,
there's no way a deer is going to be fast enough to get between me and this
truck and uh,
if he hits it,
he's just going to see,
here's what he's going to hit it,
slam on the brakes and I'll plow into the back of him.
People who live in West Chester go to short and West Chester,
I was a smart one.
I said,
let's keep driving up.
And I got this,
I got the better schools.
This is,
this is,
you know,
this is country money up here.
I got lucky with this house.
This is country money up here doing good.
Everybody going overseas too far.
Paul,
he realized how much the property value is dropped since you came here.
And that's the one thing with like real estate is really going to hurt you.
The second you buy it,
you lose money because you own it.
Once the world sees your face,
how's sold,
and then they got a picture of you.
I know,
I know.
I'm the your wife and kids.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
All right.
But you are such a shit show.
You know,
you're still guide them sensitive.
I knew halfway through that you couldn't roll with that.
You are not because we talk about it then drop him off.
I knew it.
I knew it though.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Don't you are shit.
You are the easiest guy to get in.
What's funny about use,
you always try to play it off.
Like,
uh,
you'll,
you'll just say like,
Jesus,
Paul,
you gonna wear that shirt tonight and you're like,
yeah,
fuck you.
This looks good.
And I swear to God,
it's like three to one duty.
We think there's some wrong with this shirt.
I like it.
Now you're going like this,
right?
Where were we?
We were,
we were in Upper Darby and you go Versie take that sweater off.
You said put in a dumpster,
put it in the ocean.
Oh,
do you had a bad period?
You're dressing way better.
You had a really bad period like the first six years.
Yeah.
Dude.
You had to grow into the fact that you were actually in show business.
I actually feel like you dress like a dad before you were a dead.
That's some of sorts of family man.
You are like at the first time I saw it was like this dude's got to have like
four kids.
There's no way with what he's wearing.
No,
I actually,
you know what,
it took me this in all seriousness,
it took me to my thirties to learn how to learn how to honestly drink like a
human excluding the other night,
drink a shit,
show you having good liquor,
dressing nice like an adult.
It takes awhile and I gotta tell you Paul,
not for nothing.
You got it.
You said you got a long way to go.
I got work to do.
You've got a long way to go.
Yeah.
But I mean I'm doing better and I look on Twitter like a Hoodie.
I've always given him shit because we did Carnegie Hall together and he showed
up wearing a j crew pullover in Air Jordans.
Oh.
It's just like,
oh my God,
a really nice sweat.
If you say one more time,
it's cashmere.
100%.
You know how much I sweat it costs.
How much Paul?
It was a couple hundred dollars sweater.
All black cashmere.
It didn't,
which was really nice.
Jeans.
It didn't look at that.
Fresh Jordan's on is awful.
Even even that animal derosa dressed up that night.
You haven't,
it looked weird.
We mean look,
we're shoes and went to Jack Cause cause his skeletal frame never quite
developed.
Joe Doesn't have collar bones.
A lot of people think he shoulders.
A lot of people think he doesn't have shoulders.
Do you remember what you told me?
Agreement.
Caroline's.
You whispered to me and then you told the crowd.
I just told [inaudible] and he believed it.
We were in a greener mccaroline and you go,
dude,
you know the roles it doesn't have collarbones right and you go,
that's why you said that.
And like,
and like you said,
it's so serious.
Like you leaned in and then you go,
no dick who doesn't have collarbones and then you went on the stage of your
trash.
Me,
they go,
I just told Versie Derosa was born without collarbones and he believed me and I
just started laughing.
Well,
because everybody always says Joe doesn't have shoulders.
And what it really is,
he is,
he has shoulders.
He's missing the meat.
That's between the neck and the shoulders.
It goes neck,
right.
The shows you were a Carnegie.
Did you wear a suit now?
You didn't wear a suit,
did you?
What did I wear?
He didn't wear a suit.
No,
I didn't.
Where he,
you said the Rosen was muttering and a sport coat and me and you were staring at
the ground.
We were all through Dallas.
Doesn't tents.
All right.
Like that was,
that was one of the fun,
the funny,
funniest,
like nervousness backs that we were all excited.
We all knew we were going to do well,
but there was just like midnight then I say some broke the ice.
Yeah we were all you set.
You sent me into Rosa up to your thing,
into your,
to your green room and know Maestro's suite and it was,
it made us even more nervous.
We're looking at all these dead composers on the wall and we're about ready to
go out there and do our shit jokes.
Yeah.
And and,
and there was this awkward silence for about like 19 seconds.
We were all just staring at the manual.
We're like staring at the floor,
kind of what everybody just had this big game moment.
Like we were like,
dude,
this is what we're going to the Superbowl right now or in the locker room.
And you kind of just like look down and you knew what was going on.
So you addressed it and you just go,
not one to fuck up or don't fuck this one up.
That would not be good night.
Now we kind of just were like,
we're breathing.
We were loud.
You said me and [inaudible] or staring at the ground.
And Derosa was muttering in a sport coat them better though.
That's what you have to do.
Something like that.
When I was telling the story in the podcast,
the last thing I'll do here,
so cause we're already up to a half hour when now the first time,
um,
when I do that French valley flight where I was going to fly the helicopter like
three hours by myself doing you fucking sitting there.
Yeah.
Just yeah,
like what's the sickest thing I've ever had to like mentally our one by
yourself?
Were you Lao or one minute one?
No,
no.
When you were,
once I left the fucking airport,
the safety,
cause I'd done the traffic pattern or whatever and I knew what to say.
Long Beach Tower,
helicopter Blahblahblahblahblah pad number three requesting left closed traffic
and I just fly around the thing and it's fine.
But now that I had to go the second,
I say Long Beach Tower,
uh,
requests a helicopter,
whatever,
requesting frequency change and I was leaving their airspace.
Like you don't understand,
like you stay on the airport where you're training for so long that you actually
get to know the sat and the people's voices in there.
So that's like comforting voices and then you hear other people's,
now you fly away and you hear other people's voices,
dude.
And it's,
yeah,
dude,
it was a,
well,
you're just looking over the city at one point called,
what the fuck am I doing?
This is so crazy.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And then keeping it together and then like,
you know,
and how that could look it over at that empty seat next to you,
like really mean how high are you up there when you're up there?
When you did your hour?
Three hour test?
Well,
it depends on,
uh,
the elevation of the grand.
You'd be,
I mean,
basically you basically try to stay like a thousand feet up,
Jesus.
And then,
um,
when you go out to French valley,
uh,
the elevation of the ground goes higher.
So even though your altimeter is saying a thousand feet,
you're actually like 600 feet or whatever.
So you keep going up.
And I don't even know if I was supposed to listen to something and change it,
but I just looked down at the ground.
I know what a thousand feet looks like.
I just kind of,
I flew it the day before with an instructor and a,
so this other instructor is supposed to be following me with this other student
who was from China,
but she was flying too slow.
So like basically I didn't even realize that.
So basically if I started to enter the traffic pattern wrong,
um,
or,
or mess something up,
she could have jumped on and helped me out or whatever.
And um,
the other person of flew Bluetooth so slow,
so I was way out in front of them.
And,
um,
I don't know,
but I just remember before I went out to go do it,
one of the instructors there,
he's a fucking riot.
And he knew because he was nervous when he did it or whatever.
So he came over and I was sitting down,
I was going over all my preflight shit,
making sure I had all the frequencies.
The 80 says I had a little drawing.
So I knew when I was looking down which highways I was passing on what,
cause you can fucking get lost up there.
Right.
It's fucking,
it's making me nervous now,
just talking about just the,
all the shit that could have potentially gone wrong.
And um,
so he just sat down next to me like sort of near me or whatever and sort of
glanced in my direction and I looked at him,
he just made one of those spaces they just don't like it just kind of went like,
oh,
here we go.
When he kind of rubbed his hands together and we both burst out laughing and I,
and I so fucking needed that.
Yeah.
Why'd you do this in the first place?
Like,
what was the,
is it like your joke where you will be able to get at or is it,
it's a combination of that.
And I grew up watching magnum Pi and when I used to see that do flying around
the helicopter seemed cool as hell.
And uh,
I started in,
I always wanted to do it,
but I always really thought I was too stupid.
I didn't think I could,
I could get through ground school or anything like that.
But then,
um,
I think once it became a bit on stage and I was saying,
I want it,
like just say it out loud,
I want to do this.
And I was thinking like,
yeah,
I do want to do this and I finally have the time in my life and you know,
when it's not cheap,
I finally got a little bit of money here.
I can do it.
Why not fly a jet when I fly an airplane?
I said,
you don't want to do that.
That's,
that's kind of gangster.
It'd be the gable to get in a jet though.
Um,
yeah,
no,
that's a,
yeah,
I dunno.
I just,
I just think helicopters a cooler because you really can fly.
Like he can just,
you can go forwards,
backwards.
You that Hummingbird,
you can just stop backwards.
Yeah.
It's just you just tilting the disk,
Huh?
The main road and it's just like,
it's like a little fan,
Paul.
That's all it is.
That's Ballsy,
dude.
I give you credit,
man.
Seriously.
I'll give you a credit to be able to do that.
Then I got to tell you it's it's way.
It's way,
dude.
I'm saying might not that fucking drive coming out to your placement
with fog in deer and all of that shit.
No street lights going through this headless horseman.
Shit.
You got up here,
man.
I'm telling you,
this is the most dangerous thing you'll ever do is drive down a highway when
it's congested and,
but it's not like traffic.
Everybody's still doing like 70 and you know,
people listen to the radio,
they get a texting,
they're doing all of this type of stuff.
People have this whole thing like,
oh,
I can't,
you know,
you're up there.
If something goes wrong,
you just plummet to your death.
It's like,
think about how many times you've driven down the highway are driven down a road
and you see that little memorial a little make shift,
the reef and the candles.
People fucking die all the time driving it,
dude,
I'm not flying up there.
And there's like,
Dude,
you understand?
You drive down a road like up here,
a little two lane road,
you're doing 40 another guy's doing 40 on the other side of the road.
All it takes them is the accidentally come over to your side.
He got a head on collision.
Not to mention on either side,
you've got trees and all this crap,
dude.
You go up to it.
There's nothing up to this other people.
But you taught and you're talking to each other.
Yeah.
So I just think it's,
it's still,
it's still dangerous,
but compared to what you're doing down here,
cool.
Walk away from a car accident.
That's what,
why the Harrison Ford walked away.
Yeah.
Say all right.
I mean that's nothing.
Why I don't like planes.
When you still land,
he's still going to be going like 60 knots.
She joined the land on which you got to do a helicopter.
You just,
you just come straight down and I'll let me after you do your flair.
Yeah.
And you just go straight down.
And it's no,
and hopefully a tail doesn't strike anything.
Well,
what sucks is you probably,
cause I told you what the most gangster thing would be,
the one of the most incredible things you could do would be this.
Bill's going to Vegas.
You headlines some shows in Vegas,
right?
You take your fucking helicopter landed on top of the Mirage.
Oh,
y'all don't think I haven't even thought about that already gets you get your
money and then you get your fucking helicopter.
You Go.
The only thing is I heard in,
in the,
the winds with the desert is no,
I wouldn't want to fly.
You can't know all the planes come in crazy.
The planes at the airport coming crazy because of the desert,
cause it'll wind and all that stuff.
So I couldn't imagine it.
Helicopter.
You're sitting up there.
Yeah,
yeah.
The sand really holds the heat and then that heats it up and then cooler air
comes in and then it shoots up.
I have to know all that other shit.
Yeah.
So what you have is this,
this you have to be lifting force Paul.
Yeah.
Which causes turbulence.
It's never an easy landing out there,
but um,
every once in a while it is,
but I,
I wouldn't want to land on top of a building anyways.
I don't think I have that skill and I just think it's good to be unbelievably
fucking windy.
And then also I would be worried like,
okay,
now I am,
I'm coming down and it's just like,
if I fuck this up,
if I fucked this up a little bit and go over this side of the building trying to
correct that,
I'm just going to,
that's been any special though.
If the opening to your special was you getting out of your funk and then going
down?
It would be,
it would be obnoxious.
How are you doing?
First of all,
I barely even know what the fuck I'm doing.
Jeff Dunham.
Jeff Dunham is like maverick from top gun.
Jeff Dunham builds his own helicopters.
Did you ever see that?
There's this whole thing on Jeff Dunham is fucking unbelievable.
It's like a fucking renaissance man.
Do you know that that whole thing with the puppets,
like this is a deal if you go out and you buy the puppet in a store and then you
become famous with it,
like the makers of the puppet can come at you and say,
well you did it with our product.
So he made his own,
right.
Yeah.
But he does make his own.
Like I would make an a frigging it kit.
It's okay.
It's all right.
Let's turn a little face on my hand.
Dude.
This guy,
like he's got like these computers,
they do like this three d three dimensional,
like design of the head and then he puts it in like this looks like a microwave
and he makes,
I can't even explain what it was like watching like,
uh,
the guy's a genius.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I really wish I knew what that,
that documentary on him was and it was all his life and it really fleshed them
out and made him a person because that guy gets a lot of shit.
Oh he does puppets and bins filled because it's like,
yeah,
he fucking,
he the guy made it as a front 12 course in the two thousands you know,
difficult.
That is,
it's like me making it as like a blacksmith,
you know what I mean?
Just
like the level of talent you've got to have.
I was absolutely blown away.
Our man,
he's a smart man.
Understatement.
Yeah.
Understatement and yeah.
I mean I'm not eventual liquids guy,
but like what he did with them with the end,
the terrorist guy I was blue was pretty clever.
I'm just saying that's not my style but got awesome.
The guy builds his own frigging helicopters,
does he?
Yeah.
You have to go and talk about balls the size of your house.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Paul.
I wouldn't get,
I wouldn't get on a skateboard that I made.
I went on on a flat sidewalk and I'd be wearing elbow pads and knee pads.
This guy gets in his and I mean,
it's insane.
So crazy if you really want to learn about,
and he would be the guy.
All right,
so we've already done 40 something minutes.
You know why Paul?
Because it's so effortless to talk to you.
All right.
This has been the Thursday,
uh,
podcasts,
Thursday,
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in whatever we're gonna call this.
Sometimes it's going to be up tonight.
Today.
Yeah.
If you don't mind,
we'll can we plugged the beautiful what?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
the show.
Yeah,
we're doing a with tonight.
We're doing a benefit for,
uh,
my brother in law,
Kevin Loncto,
um,
passed away far too soon,
but we're going to do something positive with it,
raise money and his name for a scholarship bill.
And,
um,
other comedians were really,
uh,
kind enough to Kaylee,
Bill,
Ben Bailey,
Christo kind enough to come in and do this and we're going to have a good time.
Seven 30 tonight at levity live.
Uh,
almost sold out,
but there are still some tickets available.
So if you want to pick those up,
you can pick them up at the window tonight.
Seven 30 tonight.
Levity live west,
Nyack,
New York.
Come out.
Beautiful.
All right.
Now let's go back in time and enjoy some classic hits from the Monday morning
podcast.
Bill Burr and uh,
Paul [inaudible].
We were up in Canada discussing time travel.
Enjoy
what's going the
time travel.
Um,
what time traveling Billy thrills.
if you could travel to any time period period prior to 1900,
but you were forced to live out your life there and you couldn't come back to
the present,
where would you choose to go?
Keep in mind anything before 1900 means everyone probably smells,
it dies at 40 years of age.
That's not true.
Not if you have money.
You'll live long.
Ben Franklin look for a long time and he was a fucking booze bag out there
flying his kite in the rain.
Did he live long?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he lived to like be like 70.
Oh,
wow.
Yeah.
And he went out there with his kite in the rain and it was fucking shit faced.
So he had his house keys tied to the thing.
That's the real story.
How we discovered electricity was fucking hammered you serious?
Yeah.
He was out of his fucking mind.
And if he was actually stone sober,
he probably would have died because he would attend stuff when he got
electrocuted.
But cause he was drunk,
he was all relaxed.
Like,
hey man,
he just rolled down the hill,
landed on his ball.
That's actually how I went bald.
He went down the hill,
like one of the lightning struck,
they hit the key in and blew his head off.
What new studies have shown all of this?
Oh,
I thought it was just fucking male pattern baldness.
No,
he got elected.
like 30% of people,
this is the worst thing they never talk about.
If you get struck by lightning like you immediately,
it blows off that top part.
You serious?
Yeah.
And it doesn't come back either.
It wouldn't make a difference with me,
but that's why Mike Michael Bolton does that.
Yeah.
He does that charity thing for a don't tell him he does a charity for people
that get struck by lightning got blown.
I can't believe you believe in this shit.
I'm just making all this up.
Yeah,
the fucking top of the head.
You know it doesn't,
but does he have a charity,
Michael Boat?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but not for that.
No.
Fuck ain't committed to that.
I did.
All right,
let's continue.
This fucking
dude that was getting so deep,
I couldn't keep a straight face.
I'm like,
there's no way he's believing in this one.
All right,
this one,
get it down the hill.
I said,
that's how he went bald and they go,
no,
no.
Wait,
here's a better life.
You still like really?
Is that what happened?
That Jesus Christ Paul,
what's the world coming to?
All right Paul,
if you could live any time period before 1900 anywhere.
Anytime.
Oh Man.
Where would you go?
I don't know.
I would go somewhere where there was a war,
but wait,
but in the question,
can I take things from present
so you could time travel to any period?
okay.
Do,
what the fuck would you bring here?
The second you pulled anything out,
they think you were a witch and they kill you.
What I'm saying is I would go to there with like shit that they don't have now.
That's what I'm saying.
Like in a war zone,
I fucking just lace.
Like if I took a side,
you know,
you go with a couple uzis or a fucking machine gun.
He just fucking leg.
Whether you be a fucking God forever,
it'd be a hero.
You know?
You'd be like,
you'd be good God,
what are you gonna do?
You're just gonna walk out in the field and use Nike fucking sweatshirt.
It Jordan's.
Yeah,
just walk out,
dress like this.
And they would be like,
you know when they were packing muskets and doing the whole thing and I'd be
like,
no,
no guys,
I got this.
What year?
Just so I just fucking,
and they would be like,
oh my God,
but just be the fucking man forever.
I'd be the man forever.
You imagine that?
Yeah.
I'm trying to wrap my head around where they're not completely freaked out by
you.
You're going to go first of all,
first of all,
what year are you going back to?
Well,
he said why?
He said prior 1900.
Yeah.
So what year are you going back to?
Uh,
the pack and Musket.
So what are we talking here?
Uh,
well there was a couple of wonder,
oh,
what is it like 18 like 18,
17,
1870s right.
Well by 1870s they had like the Winchesters and those repeating rifles and that
they actually had their first like machine gun,
the civil war,
I believe Spanish American.
Anyways,
we had the little frank,
if you fucking mowed them down,
I go before that time then.
So you're talking like I,
if I was you I would go early 18 hundreds.
Okay.
So I'd go early 18 hundreds.
Yup.
And I would bring some sort of,
who are you going to mow down?
Um,
what if you went in the French and Indian war and you actually found on the side
of the Indians what year was just mow down a bunch of French people,
whichever side I decided to choose,
like when I got there and they saw that I showed up from a time machine,
right?
One group's going to be nicer to me right now,
they're all going to be completely freaked out by it.
Right?
There's going to be the one who was a threat and you'll probably have to turn
your Uzi on them.
Then you'd have to steal their clothes
and then try to fucking do an accent.
I would choose a side of the people that were the nicest,
warmest to me when I got there,
and then I would fucking become their savior.
Nobody's going to be nice to Paul.
You understand that?
If I did it,
they would rewrite the book on me.
They would read,
they would be a mythical I,
they would kill you,
kill you.
They would kill you.
They would tell stories happened to Jesus.
No,
they would tell what happened at Jesus.
They got crucified.
Uzi.
Okay.
So yeah,
but you're going to run out of bullets.
So,
no,
but I'm in the question.
It doesn't specify like what I'm coming with.
I'm going to go prepare.
How big is his fucking time machine?
No,
no,
no.
I'm going to go with like a bunch of clips and a couple of Uzis.
Okay.
And they're gonna write fucking stories about me ordering cycle from the fucking
future.
Some mythical lazy,
close,
Lazy,
some Italian do front of you or they're not even know what New York is.
I actually,
maybe the other thing they want to know.
Yeah,
there you,
you're not listening.
You Paul.
This is the key.
They wouldn't all kill me,
but Paul is,
Hey,
I'm here to help.
So listen,
I got,
I came to this,
I can't listen to what I would tell him.
Okay.
And then you tell him what you'd say.
I say,
look,
I came from the future to help you.
This machine brought me here to help you.
I'm going to solve your problems.
And then I would fuck a pull out.
And let me ask you this cloth to this.
Let's say,
okay,
fucking after this tour,
you can't sleep one night and you look out your back yard and you see this
fucking thing appear out of nowhere.
And this guy gets out and starts walking towards your fucking house from a time
machine
and let's just say you have a shotgun and this guy walks up.
He goes,
no,
no.
Hey,
listen,
Paul Paul and he's wearing these weird workout clothes from 300 years in the
future.
Listen,
I'm here to help you.
I'm here to do things that you're gonna like you're going to fucking trust this
guy because I was sleeping in my bed and,
and I'm not.
I'm talking about,
I want to show up into a conflict.
I want to show up to the moment of a conflict and fucking take a side and when
it,
I want to win the game for the team.
This is what I'm saying.
It's a very narcissistic behavior here.
You know,
you think he's just going to show up on a battlefield,
they're going to be like our brain show up and you fucking walk out of this
thing with a hoodie sweatshirt.
And a fucking Uzi.
Yeah.
And the,
the,
the union army and the rebels are not like one of them is one of them's going to
embrace you.
Yeah.
One of those groups,
they're losing fathers and sons.
And I go,
I got this fucked a musket and I just fucking,
I just fucking lays out an army.
They're going to look at me like,
dude,
this guy were they gonna do,
they're gonna go that we've been saved this.
He was say what?
Once they realize you are mortal,
they would fucking,
probably,
they would,
they would take your weapons is what they would do.
How'd it get in the UC from me?
If they're fucking pack in a musket and they have knives because what he's
talking and Paul can cause you're gonna have your fucking back to him.
If he's shooting at the other guy,
Paul,
you know what they're gonna do.
They're gonna Probably Act nice to you.
And then,
and then,
and then what they're going to do is they're going to try to figure out where
the fuck you came from.
They're going immediately confiscate your fucking time machine and they're going
to try to see if they can do weight so they can run the fucking world to how
they're going to confiscate the time machine from me when I'm the one with the
Ammo,
I'm the one with the semiautomatic weapons.
I'm the one who's just say,
what are they going to do here?
What are they going to do?
Paul is they're going to fucking put an all points out on every fucking Goddamn
tree out there wanted sweatpant guy from the future.
This man alone has been in this time zone,
this error for fucking 20 minutes and he's already killed
600 feet.
No.
Here's the thing.
The question was where would you go and if you couldn't come back,
if I survived this all did you,
did you,
did you see ledger did forget about,
I know you didn't read anything in history.
Yeah.
Okay.
World War that does muskets in 1870.
I mean in 1870,
like I just laughed so hard to see in thoughts.
No.
Um,
world war two I read about,
I read about shit.
You literally sound like you sitting on a stoop right now.
I know stuff.
God,
what was the question?
I was going to ask if I was going to talk about people in history,
but how about like,
just we'll go with movies.
All right.
You saw there will be blood.
Yes.
Okay.
That's based off like the robber barons,
uh,
of,
of the fucking,
you know,
17,
1800 hundreds.
The,
uh,
the people you got involved in the oil rig,
the railroad guys,
the Rockefellers,
the Vanderbilts,
the fucking people who like fucking start it at all.
Yeah.
They came over here,
right?
They fucking got it.
You know,
they just,
it was wide open.
You can do whatever the fuck you want and they,
they did it.
All right.
It's funny,
I've made fun of you for being stupid.
I can't even explain this.
These guys,
the JP Morgans and all these types of fuck guys,
when you show up with this machine where they can fucking change the past,
they can change the fucking future.
These sociopaths psychos are not going to let you,
Paul Versey.
Once they fucking sit down and they talk to you,
Paul,
take day.
See where the fuck you're at.
They will pretend to be friends with you.
And when the second you shut down your,
your Uzi to have a little bit of mutton with them at the villa,
they would cut you ear to ear.
First of all,
I'm too fucking street smart to ever put my Aussie down and let them fund start
fucking drinking tea and eating crumpets with this phone.
Like how you think you're street smart and every fucking error.
Like you know what the signs are in 18 12th you think I'm gonna leave my fucking
Uzi down when nobody's got one that's gold to those people.
That's,
that's,
that's ends up to his problems.
I would never do that.
You're going to become friends with these people always having a gun trained on
them.
So you're telling me how about this,
this is what I could also do.
I could get there in my time machine and I could befriend one person and I could
let them know that I'm here to help them if they need and tell him when I could
do.
And then maybe they can say,
hey listen,
when we get into,
you know,
when the rebels come,
I've got a guy,
you know what,
I wasn't even listening.
I was thinking about what I was going to do.
All right,
well what would you do?
I would go back to once in 1900.
I would go back anyway,
keep in mind anything before eight prior to 1900,
I would go back to 1899.
Okay.
Cause I want the most up to date and medical fucking shit available for when I
come down with polio.
Whatever bullshit that's going to hit me.
Um,
I would,
I would do is I would try out and make a major league baseball team and I would
fucking destroy them with my,
uh,
with my knowledge of nutrition,
my hundred year,
120 years in the future of my knowledge of nutrition.
You know what I would do,
I would take some tea ds back with me before they even know how to test for it
and I would fucking roid up.
Fucking just give Bruce and I would try out for the Boston Red Sox and we would
win it for every fucking year of right through the twenties that's a great idea.
That's what I would do.
But you'd have to go back with steroids.
Yeah.
You'd have to go back.
You'd have to convince these people that you're going to inject.
Still don't think I could hit a curve ball.
Huh?
I still don't think I could hit a fucking curve ball,
but I just figured if I went back to the fucking look,
I couldn't make them.
I couldn't make a major league baseball team in the 19 hundreds but I think I
could make one in the 1890 so just I would have me go back.
When did it start?
1880 join the fucking Phillies.
I wouldn't want them to win a championship.
Whenever the one of the fucking red sox come around,
they was the first city the red sox came around.
And what not and the 18 early 19 hundreds
okay.
I'd like to play whenever they,
they built Fenway in 1912 I would just like to come up to bat.
God Damn.
And I couldn't do it,
so I'd have to go back.
But I'm my age now.
I'd be too fucking old by then.
Okay.
Fuck him.
He can still kill it though.
All right.
This is what I would do.
I become totally fluid in Latin and a,
I would fucking go back and I'd watch a game at the Roman Colosseum.
That's fine.
I'm trying to sports related.
I would just take my chances with,
I would just go with the heavy artillery.
I would be,
I would be a defense.
you know,
I'm going the Ronald Reagan route,
just spend it,
all of them,
all the money on defect.
I would hope that they would utilize me that way as an asset military wise.
You know,
dude,
you're out of your mind dude.
Why?
Like just me going back thinking that I could fucking make a team because I
looked at buying those 1890s like did.
They will like softball teams,
so just had ringers there.
That's,
you know,
all those guys didn't stretch do,
but you know,
you just want to ask you how can a wild west days,
they fucking went outside and they went back to back and then 10 faces.
I fucking get rid of that man.
I'm talking about,
I have everything I'm going to ask.
You don't have anything,
Paul,
what do you have is a gun and bullets.
You have the best gun,
right?
With the best bullets,
but you're ignoring the fact that an entire army is going to go after you,
that they're not going to allow it up the hill and went break them.
They're not going to allow you.
They wouldn't allow you to take pop,
by the way,
for the way that you've seized power.
As you assimilate and you worked your way up through the ranks and then you have
a new strike when the time is right.
That's how you do it.
If you try and start your own shoe,
come in,
they're all rogue.
And I was like,
listen,
I have better shit then you guys could ever dream of having,
but don't worry,
I'm your friend.
These fucking paranoid assholes,
these control freaks as they want,
that you could not live.
They would be smearing you in,
in the,
the,
the paper with every fucking day.
There's talking about this reminds me of that.
You were a big of a threat than the savages that need to be clear.
They would,
they would put you above getting rid of native Americans at that point.
You would have to be eliminated,
but not before they found out how took apart the gun to figure out how it works.
Tortured you for all the fucking,
um,
knowledge that you had and grilled you about that time machine to figure out if
you built it or he just fucking used it.
So what if I lied to him and I said,
I could get more of this.
I got a time machine.
Nobody knows where it is,
but I could go back and get more of this like so if they knew that I could,
I could,
you know what I mean?
If I lied to him that that's the best.
That's the best move you've sent out to all of this scenario where maybe you
know you could do a play on their greed and their desire to have more.
That's actually a smart fucking move.
But if you just think that you're just going to show up with your fucking cigar
and your Uzi and come walking out on a battlefield through this gets,
I'll just do this and just change the course of history depending on who was
nicer to you.
What if the Germans were nice view and world war two I mean,
you know they had nice uniforms.
Paul,
you're going to sign with them.
How funny would it be?
Just watching me going there with air maxes on Nike Air Max is on a cigar and
it's the white chair and I'm like,
listen,
sit down.
I got a gun that could solve it and I just show the guy I would love to.
I would fucking love to see the looks on their faces and then all of a sudden
they rebel against me.
I think if,
I think if you actually,
if you actually went out there and you mowed down the whole other side with what
you had.
Yeah,
that was my original.
That's what I would think that if I was on the on of the,
on your side,
I would slowly be backing away as you were doing it and then I would slip into
the woods and fucking runaway is what I would do.
I would get the fuck away from you because I don't pull,
you understand what the fuck I'm seeing.
Okay.
You can show up in your space close with you fucking ray gun.
I mean it's just like I'm out of their fucking out of there.
I'm going to leave and if you come towards me,
I'm going to shoot.
I mean if a fucking alien landed and I had a gun,
fuck his ray gun,
we fuck all that bullshit.
If it starts coming towards me,
I got to shoot at it.
If that happened,
I'd be living in the biggest house in the 18th I have all the women would be
fun.
I would be the fucking Jesus there.
They would fucking draw pictures of,
do you know what it is,
Paul?
This is your own little narcissistic head trip and that's the exact thing that
would bring you down.
You know something.
I think that this was a great answer to your listener's question while you're
acting.
You are,
I love about all of this,
Paul.
You're acting like you know how to make a fucking Uzi tiny machine.
You're going to bring one.
So I did was bring it and they're going to figure it out because the scientists
back then were just as brilliant as a scientist.
Now they just don't have the information that the ones do today.
So they would immediately break down your fucking what you are that you're asked
to take my gun,
that you're a stand up comedian.
That's what they would do.
Well,
what are you going to do,
Paul?
What are you gonna do for food?
You got an Uzi Adair.
Okay.
And then did you know how to start a fire without some wood?
Yeah,
rob,
to get,
you know how to do that.
Yeah.
How do you do it?
You know how to start a fire without matches.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've seen it done.
I've watched it onto TV.
I've seen it on the fucking,
I've seen it on youtube.
I did.
I fucking sit in on youtube when we ran a matches at the house one time.
I swear to God I was watching a clip.
Yeah.
Have watched it to the guy sat down and have you done it yet?
He gets the driest,
whatever they call it,
the grass or the dry fucking Paul.
I'm gonna tell you this right now.
They fucking,
if you can make,
if you could start a fire,
twist the thing they right.
If you could start a fire tonight.
All right,
we'll go to the Toronto Central Park.
If you could start a fight,
a fight,
a fire.
I'll give you all the money.
I'm going to make it on this tour with don't watch the youtube video again.
I want to see you start this fucking far.
Okay.
And if you don't some wood or style,
if you don't,
then you have to walk into the fucking into Lake Ontario with the Jordan on,
but 30 and shit.
Well,
that's the point.
I want you to suffer.
You're hilarious.
You're like,
yeah,
you did see it.
Wow.